terrorize as clearly is an act of terror
attempting to undermine our free press
and leaders of this country through acts
of violence I want to make very clear
that the people of New York City will
not be intimidated that we are going to
go about our lives undeterred because
the very concept of terrorism is to
change us and we will not allow that to
happen you cannot be terrorized if you
refuse to allow the terrorists to win
people in the city have shown time and
again that they stand up in the face of
these efforts to intimidate and I want
to thank the people in New York City for
the way they're handling this situation
today I also want to thank our first
responders Commissioner to you and all
the men and women of the NYPD thank you
for your extraordinary efforts today the
FDNY Office of Emergency Management our
state partners our federal partners
everyone works swiftly to address this
situation and contain it I also want to
commend everyone at CNN for the
professionalism with which they handle
this very troubling incident we at this
time do not have other credible and
specific threats against locations in
New York City I want to let all New
Yorkers know you can go about your daily
routine
knowing the NYPD and all these other
agencies are here to protect you it's
important to note that this is an
ongoing investigation as we have more
information we will provide it but I
emphasize there is no specific threat
against any other location in this city
at this time that said the NYPD and all
of our partners have reinforced our very
clear visible presence at key media
locations around New York City and other
important locations so you will see a
lot more police presence that should be
reassuring to all New Yorkers
finally I want to say this is a very
painful time in our nation it's a time
when people are feeling a lot of hatred
in the air and incidents like this
exacerbate that pain and exacerbate that
fear we cannot let the acts of a very
few change who we are it's really
important at a moment like this to
remember the vast majority of Americans
the vast majority of New Yorkers are
good people trying to live in peace with
each other
there are a few people we don't know who
they are today but there are a few
people trying to tear us apart through
acts of violence it is imperative that
we ensure they fail it is imperative
that we act as the good and decent
people that we are this is a moment in
history as painful but it will pass this
too shall pass
but today the important point is
everyone can rest assured the NYPD and
all other agencies are out and forced to
protect the people of this city and to
make sure that they can go about their
lives safely Thank You Governor Cuomo
thank you Thank You mayor Thank You
commissioner first let's remember that
we have the best police force and the
best law enforcement agencies on the
globe and we want to thank the NYPD in
the State Police and the FBI and the
Joint Terrorism Task Force the Secret
Service all who have worked seamlessly
together and are coordinated and we
should take comfort in that level of
professionalism
we have in this city and in this state
as everyone is aware they've been a
number of packages that have been
received last night there was the Secret
Service detected a package at the
residence of President Clinton and
Hillary Rodham Clinton they notified the
State Police in the NYPD we personally
checked on the president's residence in
Chappaqua at about 4:30 this morning and
everything was fine there this morning
obviously we have the CNN package and I
want to echo the professionalism with
which CNN has handled the situation and
the cooperation that they brought to the
situation so I would like to thank them
for that this is the world we live in
terrorism the attempt to spread fear is
the world that we live
it is heightened lately the mayor is
exactly right there are more tensions
than usual but this is the world we live
in also a little perspective the first
terrorist attack in New York City was
1993 25 years ago was the bombing of the
World Trade Center so in some ways this
is nothing new we have lived with this
for a long time actually my father was
governor at that time this has been a
circumstance of being who we are and
where we are we are New York and we are
an international icon and for some we're
an international target terrorism only
works if you let it work what they are
trying to do is scare us and destabilize
us and we will not allow that to happen
we are New Yorkers we are smart we are
tough we are resilient and we will not
allow these terrorist thugs to change
the way we live our lives they fail
unless we allow them to win and we will
not allow them to win
now as the Commissioner said you'll see
increased police presence from the NYPD
from the State Police from the MTA
police from the Port Authority police
you shouldn't be alarmed there'll be
more police on subways more police on
the streets more police at crossings
as the mayor said that's not because we
know any specific threat it is just a
precaution because we are smart and
because we have the best talent on the
globe when it comes to this so we will
take every precaution we can but we will
not let terrorism win not today not ever
thank you
the afternoon special agent-in-charge
brian Parman as PA AR ma NN - a special
agent in charge of the FBI's Joint
Terrorism Task Force here in New York
City as the governor outlined this
begins on Monday night with a package
that was delivered to a residence in
Westchester County that was responded to
by the Westchester County Police the
Bedford police and FBI special agent
bomb technicians that package was
disrupted and taken to the FBI lab
overnight late last night we received
word of the package that was delivered
to the Clinton residence or was
intercepted before delivery to the
Clinton residence in Chappaqua New York
that is also going to the FBI lab after
that we were notified by the Secret
Service that they had received a nearly
identical package in Washington
addressed to the Obamas at that point we
began to take additional proactive steps
we had gone to locations the day before
associated with the first individual was
targeted today we went out to Offices of
elected officials media outlets
television and in fact when the package
was discovered here in the CNN mailroom
we had NYPD personnel present who were
showing them what these look like and
what - be on the lookout for so at this
point we are talking with other FBI
field offices the JTTF about other
incidents that are unfolding in other
places but suffice it to say it appears
that an individual or individuals sent
out multiple similar packages we have
been working with corporate partners and
the private sector we've prepared a
product through the NYPD's shield
program
which goes to approximately 20,000 of
our private security partners
instructing them on what to look for
what the characteristics are and renewed
tips on on handling of suspicious
packages at this point we're at a very
early stage in the investigation this is
being led by the Joint Terrorism Task
Force here in New York City with the FBI
the NYPD we've had assistance from the
New York State Police or part of that
task force and assistance from the
Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms
so it's a big group effort the incident
here today once the package was
discovered emergency service was
notified they called the bomb squad the
bomb squad was able to safely remove a
device contained in that package using
the total containment vessel the tcv or
in simple terms the bomb truck that has
gone to our range of Rodman's neck where
FBI Special Agent bomb technicians will
work with our people on how to get it to
the next stop which should be the FBI
lab so all of this evidence can be
examined together there is an additional
issue which is being worked on now which
is within the package that contained the
suspected device is also some kind of
powder that's being tested now
downstairs so the mailroom area still
being contained while we go through the
various steps to test that on a field
test package it up safely for removal
and decon that area and anybody who came
into contact with it
you want leave the pleasure to take just
keep in mind this just happened a couple
hours ago it's still ongoing
I'm gonna take some questions we're not
gonna be able to go too deep into it yes
but take a look at who's being targeted
here right now and that's that's why
we're doing this proactively we're
reaching out to people throughout the
city checking with the people that do
their security and making sure that
they'll mailrooms follow proper protocol
so it is of concern to us and that's how
come we're reaching out to the right
people yes
look I'm just going to say something
broad because at a time when there's a
lot of hatred and division it does not
make sense to exacerbate it let's just
say this to all public officials of all
partisan affiliations don't encourage
violence
don't encourage hatred don't encourage
attacks on media you could disagree but
you have to show respect for people and
air your disagreements peacefully so
unfortunately this atmosphere of hatred
is contributing to the choices people
are making to turn to violence there's
no question about it and the way to stop
that is to turn back the other way to
bring down the temperature to end any
messages about the use of violence
against people we disagree with and that
has to start at the top this is a this
is a political year it's a political
season we are weeks from an election and
that's obviously in the air and that's
an obvious fact but we've been through
many political seasons and we have
political differences and that's
actually good for democracy what is not
good is overheated rhetoric extremism
that pushes people to violence and at
the end of the day we may have political
differences but this is one country
where all Americans
he pluribus unum out of many one and
keeping the debate and the dialogue
civil is very very important and for
elected leaders who in many ways set the
tone it is especially important
hold on hold on right there Brian Harmon
from FBI JTTF so far the the devices
have been what appear to be pipe bombs
it's uh if I could I'd like to make it
statement I know that a lot of the
public right now is scared and concerned
and there's a lot of confusion
surrounding this I want to assure you
that the reason we are here because the
totality of the federal state and local
authorities will investigate this
thoroughly and follow every lead and
every we will turn over every rock we
will turn every corner and we will talk
to everybody that we have to in order to
mitigate this threat
the mission of the New York Joint
Terrorism Task Force and is to protect
the American people and uphold the
Constitution the utilization of violence
in order to further one's own political
agenda is unacceptable to us and we will
not rest until we find this stop these
hazardous devices from being mailed and
bring the individual or individuals to
justice we have no better partners in
the NYPD the New York State Police and
the entirety of the Joint Terrorism Task
Force we will be on this until the day
that we find this individual and bring
him to justice
I'd like to thank my PD and our partners
on the task force as well as the United
States Secret Service as well as the US
Capitol Police as well as the
Westchester County authorities for the
cooperation and collaboration that we
have thus far
and with that I'll turn it back over for
questions
the as you've heard there is a number of
devices and there's a pattern apparently
to the number of devices we wouldn't be
at all surprised if more devices show up
a device has been sent to my office in
Manhattan which we were just informed
about and that device is also being
handled so again this is a situation a
number of devices have been sent they're
being handled we wouldn't be surprised
if additional devices are sent and the
device that is been said to my office
has been identified and is being handled
as we speak
well
terrorism-related right terrorism is an
attempt to strike terror an attempt to
strike fear obviously these devices are
an attempt to strike fear and terrorism
are they domestic or the international
these are all questions that would have
to be handled by the investigation but
yes it was a terrorist attempt it was a
terrorist attack and as you said what's
the intent to strike fear and when they
strike fear they win that's when they
are effective who controls that we
control that we control them this is not
the first time we have been through this
we have been through this many many
times literally as I mentioned before it
goes back 25 years to the first World
Trade Center bombing this is New York it
is part of who we are and part of our
profile so we refuse to be intimidated
we refuse to allow them to make us
afraid of going through our daily life
we have the best law enforcement
agencies we're all working together
we're all here
and we're going to go about our daily
lives enjoying this beautiful city and
state and we're not going to let them
win period Kate you had a question
yes all and I'm not gonna go into what
was on the package okay it was worth it
was consistent with the other packaging
though listen we we have to go back to
work so we're going to give you updates
throughout the day I just want to remind
everybody here in all New Yorkers any
tips any leads call nine-one-one or 1
888 NYC safe thank you very much
everybody
thank you